time now for our defending the first
series where we expose the enemies of
the First Amendment free expression and
free thought the media Research Center
released a devastating report today
documenting the censorship of
conservative speech by Silicon Valley's
tolerant tech giants among the findings
claims from former employees that
Facebook hides conservative content from
the trending section were backed up by a
detailed study Google YouTube and
Twitter partner with leftist groups like
the Southern Poverty Law Center I hate
conservatives and check this out of the
25 members on the panel that guides
Twitter's policies twelve are liberals
and there's only one conservative I
can't believe there's one shocking well
but not surprising is it for more
details we're joined by brent bozell
founder of the very important
indispensable media Research Center
Brandt first of all it's great to have
you first appearance on the show man oh
yeah where have you been tell us what
you found
what's a massive study done by my
colleagues Dan Gainor and Ashley
Goldenberg it's 50 pages documenting
what what conservatives have been
suggesting has been happening this is
Michelle's hyperbolic but Laura this is
true this is the emerging the greatest
censorship of free speech worldwide in
the history of man and let me explain
this the left is on a jihad against
conservative thought is happening in
academia in entertainment and business
religion everywhere everywhere where
they're attacking they're suppressing
conservative thought now they're going
to the social media giants these social
media giants have audiences in the
billions and what we've shown in this
massive report is whether it's Facebook
or Twitter or Google or YouTube they're
all employing different tactics to go
against conservative let's go through
some of them we have a full screen on
this censorship of conservative speech
here's some examples Google search AIDS
Democrats and study found that 2016
campaign search
were biased in favor of Hillary Hillary
Clinton YouTube shutting down
conservative channels by mistake by
removing videos that promote right-wing
political views and tech companies
Facebook and Google are relying on anti
conservative fact checkers like Snopes
and Wikipedia
now why is Wikipedia for our viewers out
there why is that a left-wing well if
you if you look at so many things
Wikipedia does it puts a liberal spin
against conservatives on a regular basis
we always have to edit my page it just
insert insert inside nasty stuff about
you know they have been they've actually
they've been partnering YouTube has been
partnering with them to unmask
conservatives and to go against
conservative content and to uncover
these awful conservatives and what
they're doing you say that war is being
declared on the conservative movement
and conservatives are losing badly if
the right is silenced billions of people
will be cut off from conservative ideals
it goes on but we'll just stop it there
that's really true isn't it because even
though the Soviets suppress speech China
suppresses speech we're talking about in
effect a global effort to suppress or
silence conservatives when you've seen
well you know the nonsense that's
happened to shows like mine they try to
do it with Rush and others this is what
they do they don't want to debate
because they're losing on the substance
are they not they want to silence but
with the power of high tech Brent what
can we the consumers of information and
and others watching what can they do
well the for the first thing you have to
do is recognize what is going on right
now you know Jack Dorsey is the CEO of
Twitter he put these seasoned industry
perspective just recently he was
promoted he promoted an article that
called for the destruction of the
conservative movement promoted he
related so it's not it's not just
happening United States it's all over
the world that the left is militant
conservatives have to recognize this and
conservatives have to start looking for
new homes our own platforms I think we
are grew does that hold them accountable
but bark sorry on yours of conservative
leads if they could if they leave the
business model for these social media
giant skulls your power with
businesses high-tech everybody
resolutions that your audience is up 20%
ever since they went after you well you
know we there's always a glass half full
here on the in on the Ingraham angle
Brent thank you we're gonna we're gonna
link this up on my Facebook page
everybody needs to read it and support
the efforts that you're doing I don't
know what would do with it without media
Research Center frankly thank you so
much